[Musique]
ça fait maintenant plusieurs je dirais
décennies presque que la france ou
financent sa recherche et son
enseignement supérieur à quoi est-ce que
vous attribuez ce manque de moyens c'est
un un problème politique au sens où ça
serait à gauche dans le projet politique
la recherche n'a pas la place qu'elles
devraient avoir parce que la recherche
est un élément central dans la prise en
compte et très très grands défis face
auxquels nous sommes aimés en
particulier le défi qui pète ses
conséquences et notamment les problémes
ni là c'est la première mêlée qui va y
en avoir d'autres
il faut qu'il y ait une prise de
conscience collective vraiment
il a mis le feu à la maison déclarations
des policiers français qui ont continué
de manifester aujourd'hui après les
propos de leurs ministres lundi
christophe castaner a annoncé de
possibles suspensions en cas de
suspicion avérée de racisme dans les
rangs de la police
les syndicats ont été reçus place
gouraud aujourd'hui ils demandent aussi
à parler au président de la république
[Musique]
un assouplissement des mesures
sanitaires plus tôt que prévu en france
pour relancer le tourisme et la
restauration en zone d'épidémie
l'union européenne est appelée à rouvrir
ses frontières dans trois jours à
l'exception de l'espagne à des
mouvements de population qui inquiète le
m s alors que la pandémie progresse en
afrique et dans les outre-mer en italie
le premier ministre a été entendu par un
juge pour des retards présumées dans la
gestion de la crise
[Musique]
les états unis profère de nouvelles
menaces contre la cour pénale
internationale la cpi qui enquête sur
deux dossiers gênants pour washington
les crimes présumés des soldats
américains et de la cia en afghanistan
et la colonisation des territoires
palestiniens
washington a ordonné des sanctions
contre des officiels du tribunal de la
haye et contre des fonctionnaires
impliqués dans ces dossiers
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce vendredi la colère des
policiers français qui s'estiment lâchés
par leur ministre il ne lui font plus
confiance
christophe castaner a reçu aujourd'hui
les syndicats de police les uns après
les autres pour tenter d'apaiser les
tensions
voyez les précisions depuis la place
beauvau de notre reporter estelle
chargent à tour de rôle à christophe
castaner a reçu aujourd'hui les
secrétaires généraux des syndicats des
officiers et des commissaires devant les
syndicalistes le ministre de l'intérieur
a reconnu avoir eu des propos maladroits
en début de semaine il a évoqué un
défaut de communication je vous propose
d'écouter à ce propos patrice ribeiro
secrétaire général du syndicat synergie
officiers
on a eu donc une explication de la part
du ministre de l'intérieur qui se résume
un défaut de communication et qui lave
rassemblement selon ses mots dit une
connerie
donc il va rétablir éclaircir ses propos
et puis
vraisemblablement s'adresser dans un
premier temps aux organisations
syndicales ce soir en expliquant ses
propos et s'adresser vraisemblablement
aussi individuellement aux policiers
dans les semaines qui viennent
nous avons eu la rencontre que l'on elle
n'attendait s'est de son côté à ce qu'a
déclaré david le bars le patron du
syndicat des commissaires tout en
précisant que christophe castaner à
l'eat adressé une lettre ce soir aux
organisations syndicales
on a eu la rencontre qu'on attendait
donc déjà premier point satisfecit par
rapport à l' écoute
le ministre est très claire sur le
soupçon avérée on tourne une page c'est
un propos maladroits il le reconnaît il
a déjà dit dans les médias il nous l'a
redit évidemment que c'est pas le
soupçon qui condamne le policier c'est
la faute donc là dessus premier point
elle est le deuxième point on lui a fait
savoir qu'il n'est pas question de sens
que dans une zone grise avec des
techniques d'interpellation qui ne sont
plus possibles parce qu'elles ont été
interdites
donc il est conscient de ce problème
alors fait ça s'appelle une prise
arrière ou pas la question c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on va employer dans les
jours à venir avant qu'on mette en place
d'autres techniques on ne peut pas
attendre les réflexions d'un groupe de
travail donc il va nous écrire
ce soir il va rapidement trancher mais
nous assurer qu aurait pas de zones
grises et donc on ne laisserait pas les
policiers sans la capacité de procéder à
leur métier à leur coeur de métier à
savoir interpeller les récalcitrants et
dans cette lettre les organisations
syndicales espèrent entre autres que le
ministre de l'intérieur reviendra sur
son âne annonce d' interdire certaines
techniques d'interpellation et notamment
est la clé d'étranglement avant qu'une
méthode alternative soit trouvée nous ne
laisserons pas nos frères d'armes se
faire traiter de raciste des policiers
qui d'ex qui se défendent en dénonçant
des a priori dans une tribune dans le
magazine marianne vous ne voyez une
soixantaine de policiers issus de la
diversité ont réagi aux accusations de
racisme
une vision totalement faux selon eux
leur texte affirme qu'il y a une réelle
diversité des origines ethniques dans
leurs rangs et que tous sont animés par
les mêmes valeurs républicaines et
universaliste fin de citation regardez
nous réaffirmons notre fierté
d'appartenir à la nation française
engagée pour secourir et protégé dans ce
pays où nous sommes nés dont nous avons
acquis la citoyenneté
nous condamnons les injures dégradantes
sur nos complexion selon lesquels nous
serions des vendus des [ __ ] de maisons
des arabes de service
et c'est dans ce contexte que les
conclusions du rapport d'expertisé
balistique sur la mort de zineb redouane
ont été rendus et elle disculpe la
police en décembre 2018 cette femme
algérienne a été tué après un tir de
grenade lacrymogène alors qu'elle fermer
les fenêtres de son appartement pendant
une manifestation d gilet jaune à
marseille l' expertise balistique révèle
que le policier auteur du tir a bien
respecté les règles d'utilisation de son
arme la mort de zineb red one serait
donc accidentelle voyez la réaction de
samir redouane c'est le fils de la
victime
je suis pas je suis déçu je m'attendais
pas à ça je croyais que la justice
française va faire convenablement son
travail
nous on ne demandait rien du tout on
demander que justice soit enfin
seulement on est depuis une année et
demi qu'on est traumatisée on est rené
pas on n'a pas fait une ou deux notre
but est plutôt avec notre avocat
on va voir comment on va faire peut-être
on va demander des contre-expertises 2,8
on va pas se faire de toute façon on va
pas baisser les bras
on fera tout pour avoir un justice et
voyez la réaction de samir redouane que
l'on vient d'entendre ça mais redouane
un nouveau discours d' emmanuel lacroix
après demain pour faire un point sur la
crise sanitaire
l'elysée qui a un agenda déjà chargé
puisque ce matin où il voyait le
président de la république à rennes a
réuni le conseil scientifique et dans la
foulée un conseil de défense s'est tenue
en présence est d'edouard philippe
d'olivier verront que bruno le maire de
christophe castaner objectif définir les
contours de la suite du déconfinement le
gouvernement qui est sous pression
puisque depuis plusieurs jours des voix
s'élèvent ainsi des politiques et dans
le patronat pour accélérer la reprise
des activités économiques du pays
les chercheurs sont actuellement
mobilisées contre une loi la loi pour la
peau la loi de programmation pour la
recherche la loi pluriannuelle
exactement pour la recherche
ils ont manifesté place de la sorbonne
aujourd'hui vous le voyez le
gouvernement qui veut revaloriser les
carrières de chercheurs et augmenter le
niveau de recherche mais les
professionnels du secteur e1 craignent
une course aux financements et une
précarisation des personnels l'exécuter
qui l'exécutif qu'il souhaite présenter
cette loi le 8 juillet en conseil des
ministres voyez ce qu'en disent les
manifestants je suis là ici aujourd'hui
parce que ça fait déjà longtemps qu'on a
commencé la lutte contre la réforme elle
ppr qui est une réforme que pour le
moment on voit très libérale qui va sans
doute entraîner la fin de la fonction
publique
énormément de vacataires et c'est à dire
de précaires dans dans l'université dans
la recherche on n'accepte pas le projet
de loi lppr donc la loi de programmation
plus javier de la recherche que le
gouvernement veut faire passer à toute
vitesse cet été ça fait déjà plus d'un
an que ce projet est mis en avant par le
gouvernement et les objectifs sont
confirmés
c'est d'une part d'accentuer la
recherche sur projets c'est à dire de
moins en moins d'argent dans le soutien
de base annuelle des laboratoires je
crois que c'est important que cette
mobilisation se tiennent juste après le
confinement parce qu'on a bien vu les
désastres de cette politique notamment
avec des virologues un certain nombre de
virologues du cnrs et d'autres instituts
de recherche se sont dit clairement que
ça faisait des années qu'ils étaient
dans la morosité l'austérité parce que
les virus n'était pas des marchés
porteurs pour eu une recherche il faut
absolument que les que les laboratoires
que les collègues leur financement soit
vraiment des financements pérennes qui
puisse permettre de travailler dans
différents direction en fonction des
résultats en fonction des collaborations
en italie le premier ministre a été
entendu par un juge sur sa gestion de
l'épidémie qui a fait plus de trente
quatre mille morts josep est conté qui
assure n'avoir rien à se reprocher la
justice elle met en avant des retards
dans ce dossier françois xavier lambert
la popularité grandissante de giuseppe
compter dans les sondages ne l'empêchent
pas de rendre des comptes devant la
justice italienne
le chef du gouvernement ainsi que ses
ministres de la santé de l'intérieur
doivent s'expliquer sur un point en
particulier les retards constatés dans
la création d'une zone rouge comprenant
deux localités particulièrement touché
par le coronavirus negro et l anneau
lombardo dans le nord du pays
fin février le gouvernement italien
décidé de confiner une dizaine de
municipalités en lombardie
mais ces mesures ne concernaient pas ces
deux communes malgré les mises en garde
des experts
après de nouvelles consultations du gp
compte et signe finalement un décret qui
place toute l'italie en zone rouge le 9
mars
à l'heure du bilan le gouvernement
central et les dirigeants de la
lombardie se rejettent la responsabilité
de ce délai un confinement tardif qui
pourrait avoir entraîné la saturation du
système sanitaire lombard et une large
propagation du virus
face à la polémique et aux possibles
conséquences jeudi 6
giuseppe comptait se dit serein je ne
suis pas du tout inquiet ce n'est pas
une attitude arrogante ou supérieur je
ne commenterai pas les propos du
procureur qui ont été communiqués à
l'avant sur la rai télévision nous
comparerons nos données ce vendredi je
ferai un rapport sur tous les faits que
je connais calmement cette enquête qui
vise le pouvoir politique italien
s'ajoute un recours collectif
introduit à bergame une des villes les
plus touchées par l'épidémie
une cinquantaine de plaintes contre x
ont été déposées par des proches de
victimes du coronavirus pour ces
familles endeuillées
il s'agit d'établir des responsabilités
dans cette crise il s'agit de la
première étape nous avons réalisé
concrètement ce qui jusqu'à aujourd'hui
était limité à internet
tout a commencé avec un groupe facebook
que j'ai créé avec mon père le 22 mars
pour voir s'il y avait d'autres
personnes qui voulaient raconter leur
histoire qui à leurs yeux comportait des
zones d'ombré nous voulons la vérité
comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
recevoir justice celui qui a fait une
erreur il est juste qu'il paye pour cela
cet après midi giuseppe conté a été
entendu pendant plus de trois heures par
la procureure de bergame et voyez à
présent l'analyse de matteo ghisalberti
il est rédacteur en chef de putsch média
spécialiste de l'italie
on voit qu'il y a il renvoie la balle
entre le gouvernement et la région
lombardi mais ce n
un coin dire c'est une guerre surtout
politique parce que le gouvernement et
soutenue par des forces de centre gauche
la région lombardie par des forces de
centre-droite en particulier par la
ligue de matteo salvini qui est
considéré comme un il ne menace pas le
gouvernement mais aussi par apparemment
la présidence de la république parce que
d'ici quelques 2022 on devra aussi
renouveler le président de la république
et si on allait voter maintenant les
fort probable que le gouvernement qui
votera le prochain qui dira le prochain
président la république pour et avoir
une majorité différente favorable à la
ligue de matteo salvini l'union
européenne appelé à ouvrir ses
frontières à partir du 15 juin prochain
lundi la france le fera avec l'allemagne
et la belgique et le luxembourg mais pas
avec l'espagne ont fait le point en
images
regardez
[Musique]
cela s'appliquera à tous les pays tiers
qui sont dans une situation similaire ou
une meilleure par rapport à lieu
concernant leur situation sanitaire
ah oui si nous leur ouvrons les voyages
au sein de lieux nous espérons que ces
pays tiers s'ouvriront également au
voyage depuis nos pays vers leur
territoire et cela devra être le cas
pour tous les états membres de l'ue et
les pays associés à l'espace schengen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
le
[Musique]
le monde toujours dans l'attenté d'un
vaccin contre le coc vie de 19 pc à qui
l'aura le premier cette question avait
suscité souvenez vous la polémique entre
les états unis et l'europe à partir du
mois de juillet avec saint amé ricain
sera testé sur trente mille personnes
la course au vaccin dans le monde en
images regarder
[Rires]
oh
il
[Musique]
[Rires]
on
mon
où
[Musique]
les états unis profère de nouvelles
menaces contre la cour pénale
internationale la cpi qui enquête sur
deux dossiers gênants pour washington
les crimes présumés des soldats
américains et de la cia en afghanistan
ainsi que la colonisation des
territoires palestiniens
washington a ordonné en représailles des
sanctions contre des officiels du
tribunal de la haye et contre des
fonctionnaires impliqués dans ces
dossiers clément hospital c'est un coup
de tonnerre venu tout droit du bureau
ovale
donald trump a haussé le ton face à la
cour pénale internationale en annonçant
des sanctions à l'encontre de certains
de ses responsables pour dissuader la
juridiction de poursuivre des militaires
américains pour d'éventuels crimes de
guerre commis en afghanistan un enjeu
sur lequel l'administration trump ne
compte pas rester les bras croisés
comme l'a martelé le secrétaire d'état
my pop et l'administration de train
prend les mesures suivantes premièrement
nous autorisons l'imposition de
sanctions économiques contre les
fonctionnaires de la cour pénale
internationale et participe directement
aux efforts de la cpi pour enquêter sur
le personnel américain où le personnel
alliés contre le consentement de cet
état allié et contre d'autres qui
soutiennent matériellement les activités
de ses fonctionnaires les désignations
seront faites au cas par cas contre des
individus ou des entités spécifiques des
sanctions américaines vivement saluée
par l'allié de donald trump le premier
ministre israélien benyamin nétanyahou
car israël est également dans le viseur
de la cpi et pourrait faire l'objet
d'investigations pour crimes de guerre
en cisjordanie et dans la bande de gaza
tout d'abord je tiens à féliciter le
président trump et le secrétaire d'état
pompéo pour l'or audacieux leadership
dans les sanctions contre cette cour
pénale internationale corrompu et
partial ce tribunal kangourou et d'un
tribunal politisé il est mené par une
obsession celle de lancer des chasses
aux sorcières contre israël les états
unis et d'autres démocraties qui
respecte les droits de l'homme tout en
fermant les yeux sur les biens auteurs
d'atteintes aux droits de l'homme
dans le monde y compris le régime
terroriste dire en face à ces menaces
la cour pénale internationale a dénoncé
une série d' attaque sans précédent et
une tentative inacceptable de porter
atteinte à l'état de droit et aux
procédures judiciaires
cette annonce de la maison blanche a
également fait réagir le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell pour
qui cette posture visa refusé toute
forme de justice aux victimes de
certains crimes graves commis en
afghanistan en israël ou en palestine
la cour a joué un rôle clé dans
l'instauration d'une justice
internationale et dans la lutte contre
les plus grands crimes internationaux de
la chaîne
elle est un facteur clé pour apporter la
justice et la paix elle doit être
respectée soutenu par toutes les nations
respectées ce port auteurs nationaux des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme ont vite fait part de leur
indignation
l' ong human right watch appelle ainsi
les pays soutenant la justice
internationale à s'opposer publiquement
à cette tentative d' entrave et voyez à
présent l'analyse de gérald olivier il
est journaliste et chercheur à l'ipp ce
également spécialiste des états unis les
états unis sous la dalle trump se sont
retirés de la commission des droits de
l'homme deux des nations unies ils se
sont retirés de l'accord iranien qui
avait été au départ organisé autour
d'une résolution du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies en 2015 ils se sont
retirés de l'accord international de
paris sur le climat ils viennent de se
retirer de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
donc vous avez une série d'actions ou
les états unis préfèrent un être seul
être libre et traités avec leurs alliés
ou leurs rivaux un à un de manière
bilatérale et l'action qu'ils viennent
de prendre le décret qui a été signé et
qui est un décret très dur et très
étendues
c'est pas seulement les membres de la
cour qui sont concernées mais c'est tout
les associés ou les partenaires qui
pourraient être amenés à travailler avec
eux il ya une sorte de sanction par
association qui pénalise véritablement
dans son fonctionnement la cour
mais dans cette attitude encore une fois
les états unis sont tout à fait logique
avec avec eux-mêmes et monsieur khroub
est tout à fait cohérent avec sa
politique qui a toujours privilégié des
relations bilatérales aux relations
multilatérales
les manifestations se poursuivent au
liban à cause de la situation économique
catastrophique et l'inflation qui
pourrait attendre jusqu'à 50 % cette
année des manifestants qui dénoncent
également la corruption des dirigeantes
et aux combes atmosphère d'émeutes à
beyrouth cette nuit plusieurs centaines
de manifestants ont défié les forces de
l'ordre dans les rues de la capitale
objectif dénoncer la situation
économique catastrophique du pays et la
corruption des dirigeants source
d'inquiétude pour le gouvernement la
livre libanaise a frôlé le seuil des
5000 livres pour un dollar dans les
bureaux de change
un énième coup dur pour l'économie du
pays et sa population
officiellement à d'excès sur le dollar
depuis 1997 au taux fixe de 1507 livre
pour un dollar la monnaie libanaise est
en chute libre depuis octobre 2019
de nombreux habitants sont excédés de la
situation un dollar américain vaut 7000
livres libanaises pourquoi est ce que
les gens sont encore chez eux
tous les magasins sont fermés les gens
au fait vous manifestiez pour vos fêtes
et vos professions mais maintenant pour
votre pays vous êtes toujours acier à la
maison donc qu'est-ce que vous attendez
le gouvernement et les partis politiques
ne sont pas capables et ne veulent pas
sauver le pays de la crise actuelle
ils veulent le volet ne se soucie pas du
pays
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans les rues et
cela fait presque six mois mais
maintenant c'est insupportable parce que
la situation économique est un désastre
et que personne ne fait rien
c
plusieurs feux se sont déclarés à
beyrouth près de la place des martyrs
des centaines de protestataires en
scooter ont parcouru les rues de la
capitale afin de dénoncer riad salamé
gouverneur de la banque centrale ainsi
que le gouvernement du premier ministre
hassan diab des affrontements ont opposé
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ces
dernières ont fait usage de gaz
lacrymogènes afin de disperser la foule
des tensions aussi présente à tripoli
dans le nord du pays où des
protestataires ont tenté d'investir la
branche locale de la banque centrale
des événements qui ont fait au moins
huit blessées dans la cité côtière
en réponse à ces événements le premier
ministre hassan diab a annulé l'ensemble
des réunions prévues ce vendredi pour
convoquer d'urgence le conseil des
ministres afin de trouver des solutions
à la crise financière
en effet le pays traverse sa crise
économique la plus grave depuis la fin
de la guerre civile en 1990 des
négociations vital entre le gouvernement
libanais et le fonds monétaire
international sont en cours sur une aide
qui permettrait au pays d'enrayer
l'effondrement de son économie
une possible bouée de sauvetage pour un
état à la dérive
l'actualité internationale en bref et en
images ces manifestations en syrie des
partisans de bachar al assad
ils protestent contre les récentes
sanctions américaines et le vote de la
loi césar c'est une loi est entrée en
vigueur ce mois ci et qui prévoit le gel
de l'aide à la reconstruction du pays
un accès limité aux médicaments ou
encore de futures sanctions contre les
entreprises à qui elle collaborait avec
nous
man syrien sanctions prises par les
états unis bien sûr des manifestations
encadrées et très surveillée à hong kong
par la police plusieurs dizaines de
manifestants ce célèbre le premier
anniversaire d'un mouvement de
protestation historique
les hongkongais qui s'opposent
aujourd'hui on est toujours au projet de
loi sur la sécurité nationale
ce texte initié par pékin et soutenu par
le gouvernement local est dénoncée par
ces contestataires
il réclame la libération de l'ancienne
colonie britannique et le respect du
principe un pays deux systèmes voilà
pour leurs revendications en australie
des manifestations en hommage à georges
floyd ont été bloqués à sydney policiers
ont encerclé l'hôtel de ville où
devaient se rassembler les manifestants
des autorités qui avait indiqué par
avance que l'événement ne pouvait avoir
lieu en raison de l'épidémie les
rassemblements publics de plus de dix
personnes sont interdits comme en france
quelques centaines de manifestants se
sont toutefois regroupés dans un parc
voisin et d'autres rassemblements sont à
prévoir ce week-end en russie le
président russe a célébré aujourd'hui le
jour de la russie c'est une fête
nationale qui commémore l'accession de
la russie à l'indépendance après la fin
de l'urss en 1990 un grand défilé qui
commémore la victoire de l'union
soviétique contre l'allemagne nazie a dû
lui être organisée reporter il sera
organisera organisé le 24 juin prochain
après avoir été reportée bien sûr en
raison de la crise tout comme le vote
sur la réforme constitutionnelle
dans son discours delà des murs poutine
en a profité pour évoquer justement ce
dernier projet à écouter la préservation
de la mémoire des ancêtres le respect
des parents et de la famille l'amour de
notre terre et la fermeté de nos
frontières sont les fondements qui
détermine le caractère et le destin de
notre peuple
le développement de notre pays
aujourd'hui comme à l'avenir
des propositions pour introduire ces
principes fondamentaux dans la
constitution russe sont donc tout à fait
légitime
je suis convaincu que cette position est
partagée soutenu par la majorité absolue
de nos citoyens pour l'achat de cloche
est à l'occasion de cette fête nationale
russe de nombreux leaders mondiaux ont
adressé leur message à vladimir poutine
et à la russie ont coûté au nom du
président trump et du peuple américain
je présente mes voeux aux russes à
l'occasion du jour de la russie cette
année la fédération de russie célèbre la
signature de sa déclaration
d'indépendance pour la 30e fois
les etats unis saluent les
transformations démocratiques que la
russie avait engagé il ya trois
décennies au nom du gouvernement des
états unis du peuple américain je
félicite les citoyens de russie qui
célèbrent aujourd'hui leur fait
celle ci marque le 30e anniversaire de
la déclaration de souveraineté de l'état
russe traduisant les aspirations
démocratiques et la souveraineté du
peuple russe
c'est avec un grand plaisir que
j'adresse mes plus chaleureuses
félicitations pour votre fête nationale
et mes meilleurs voeux au peuple de
russie en ces temps difficiles
aujourd'hui le peuple russe sous votre
direction dynamique surmonte
audacieusement tous les défis et
difficultés et remporte d'importants
succès dans la construction d'une russie
forte et prospère à la grande joie
sincère du peuple nord-coréen et c'est
la fin de ce journal merci de votre
fidélité
sur notre antenne on se retrouve dans 30
minutes master i p
[Musique]
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
mondiale quel rôle doit selon vont jouer
à levin et quel rôle joue-t-elle dans
les faits les villes tout comme les
états ils n'étaient pas préparés
c'est là mais les villes elles se sont
connectés tout de suite entre elles pour
voir comment elles pouvaient coopérer
il ya eu l'envoi des beaucoup de des
masques de matériels médicaux d'une
commune à l'autre selon vous à quoi
pourront rassembler les villes comment
est-ce qu'elles vont se transformer
après la pandémie la crise maintenant à
fait bien comprendre qu'on peut pas
s'oublier des banlieues on peut pas
oublier les quartiers pauvres parce que
véritablement être en partie de la vie
donc les grandes villes quand il se
connecte
elle n'est pas seulement d'elle-même
elle parle aussi de comment créer cette
cercle vertueux avec les villes des
alentours
[Musique]
comme d'habitude on rajoute de la dette
parce qu'on aime ça
on aime beaucoup la bête pour la
première fois on parle une tête commune
à messieurs ça tout à fait nouveau
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez des
gens qui dans aux pays bas ou en france
vont vouloir aller payer des impôts pour
les grecs tout pour les italiens alors
monsieur moto pour l'italie et à
l'espagne sont allés principaux
bénéficiaires c'est un message fort
selon vous envoyez à ces pays du sud qui
se joue dans cette histoire c'est la
marche en avons tous les pays de toute
l'europe l'europe est morte enfin acté
kelly morte
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups positif a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui compte c'est qu'on soit vient
de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
on reprend notre débat pourquoi la mort
de georges fenech floyd at elle eu de
telles conséquences avec eva doumbia qui
est auteur et metteur en scène de
théâtre sa place pièce le lien jeu sera
jouée la rentrée édité par actes sud
mahboula soumahoro qui est docteur en
civilisation du monde anglophone c'est
l'auteur de du livre le triangle l
hexagone et norman à jarry et philosophe
il est l'auteur lui de la dignité ou la
mort éthique et politique de la race aux
éditions de la découverte
le fait que ce soit et georges tron le
fait que ce soit donald trump
aujourd'hui qui soit président des états
unis
est-ce que ça n'a pas joué aussi dans
dans l'indignation qui a soulevé la mort
de georges floyd ne serait ce que parce
qu'elle n'avait pas l'air de la digne et
beaucoup lui qu'il avait l'air davantage
de s'indigner de la digne à sion qu'elle
suscitait notamment des ddd
manifestations et on sait depuis que
lors de ces manifestations le président
des etats-unis a été obligé de se
réfugier dans l'abri antiatomique de la
maison blanche qui est pour le moins
humiliant alors norman el jarih vous
vous vivez aux états unis le fait que ce
soit george e donald trump c'est à dire
quand même un départ des présidents
américains qu'on soupçonne le plus de
racisme
ni nixon ni reggane ni même george bush
dans notés